der film der traumhafte blick ist der
neue film von angela schanelec die man
vielleicht kennt von allerlei gerüchte
über die sogenannte berliner schule die
wiederum so was ähnliches sein soll wie
die drewag damals in frankreich war man
kennt sie vielleicht auch von dem film
pauli den linken 8 1 2010
und dieser neue film ist nicht so
einfach nach zu erzählen weil ihre film
gründe sind nicht so einfach
nachzuerzählen sind weil anders als bei
karl may film man dann am nächsten tag
in der schule sein kind dem anderen kind
gesagt hat und dann hat er gefangen und
dann wird aber befreit und dann passiert
hier vieles auf eine ganz andere weise
nämlich auf eine diesen raum nimmt die
sich zeit nimmt und die mehrere
jahrzehnte in anspruch nimmt also
konstellation zwischen verschiedenen
figuren von denen aber die ein oder
andere figur dabei nicht altert und
sogar die gleichen klamotten noch an hat
30 jahre später
fotos geschäft gelungen ist interessant
für mich war
man wird ja sozusagen ein bisschen vorne
waren so wie man bei horrorfilmen
manchmal vorgewarnt wird aus dem guten
magen hafte herzprobleme die da lieber
nicht rein wird man bei dieser art film
bei dem film von angela vorgewärmt die
sind polarisieren wird so was gemeint
ist wie du wirst dich wahrscheinlich auf
regen wie lang einige einstellungen
gehen oder du hast dich wahrscheinlich
aufgeben wie menschen halb auf dem bild
starren oder die leute aneinander vorbei
reden oder so weil du aus filmen wo es
um gefühle geht wo es menschen geht
eigentlich gewohnt wird ist ihr nicht
nur alles erklärt wird was dann passiert
sondern oft sogar was sie dabei fühlen
soll es durch die entsprechende musik
und so weiter und ich war es also
tatsächlich drin sozusagen pflicht
schuldig diese pflicht erfüllen erst mal
davon irgendwie gestört zu sein und dann
drehte sich das schon beim gucken und
seitdem hatte ich immer weiter gedreht
und ich hab dann noch mal angeguckt
später und mit jedem mal wo ich gesehen
habe war mir klar dass ich sicherlich
noch mal anschauen werde es alle schon
ihre clips zum bewährten wohnung füllen
ist eigentlich wie gut sind die
schauspielerinnen und schauspieler weil
man sozusagen bei jim carrey ja leicht
wagen kann der wichtigsten lachen
bringen man hat sozusagen das ist gut
oder nicht gut oder irgend jemand der
ein oscar dafür kriegt dafür einen
sterbenden typfrage spielt weiß er da
sollte geweint weil die weihnachtsware
schauspielers gut da hier aber keine
schilder dran kleben was du irgendwie
fühlen sonst weißt du eigentlich gar
nicht ob die gut sind heißt es aber doch
sie sind nämlich dadurch gut dass du
dich das die ganze zeit weiter fragt das
die ganze zeit versucht mehr
heranzukommen
also man kann natürlich sagen üblichen
verdächtigen müssen sich da irgendwie
die schlange stellen leute die sich so
was wie das label berliner schule
interessieren leute die sich für kunst
kunst interessieren leute die sich dafür
interessieren dass eine geschichte
erzählt wird auf was bedeutet dass
abgeklopft werden kann irgend so ein f
aber ich würde sagen da die sowieso alle
reingehen kann ich auf die auch
verzichten als leute denen ich das
empfehle und so stattdessen sagen leute
die beispielsweise romantische komödien
gucken weil wieder was suchen aber oft
da raus gehen und denken ich hab's aber
nicht gefunden
und vielleicht gar nicht wissen was
untersuchen vielleicht sind es hier